Shure: 这个
Shure: This
Shure: 一楼一个二楼那
Shure: First floor one, second floor that
Shure: 我那我就是二二楼呗
Shure: Then I'll be on the second floor
Shure: 我把这菜板拿下去得了
Shure: I'll take this chopping board down
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay
Shure: 咱也就不那么讲了
Shure: Let's not talk about it then
Jake:二楼 你这个备菜工作多吗
Jake:要多久
Shure: 半个小时
Shure: Half an hour
Shure: 行行 你给这呆着吧  我以为用二楼呢
Shure: 那算了 在这吧
Shure: 差不多
Shure: 现在把剧放着
Shure: Now let's put on the play
Shure: 不然的话没有灵魂
Shure: Otherwise, it has no soul
Shure: 这板子
Shure: This board
Shure: 他居然架不上
Shure: It can't be set up
Shure: 正常应该都正好是架着一个板
Shure: Normally it should fit perfectly on a board
Shure: 我是头一回在旁边切东西
Shure: This is my first time chopping things on the side
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Shure: 还有没有其他铁盆啥的了
Shure: Are there any other iron bowls?
Shure: 不应该就这一个盆吧
Shure: There shouldn't be just one bowl, right?
Shure: 啊这有盆
Shure: Ah, here's a bowl
Shure: 德云社的一个新剧
Shure: A new play from Deyunshe
Shure: 工人帮忙打下手来了
Shure: The workers came to help
Shure: 这镯今用了吗
Shure: Did you use this bracelet today?
Shure: 这没人用了这
Shure: No one used this
Shure: 刀在哪
Shure: Where's the knife?
Shure: 刀
Shure: Knife
Shure: 是在楼上吗
Shure: Is it upstairs?
Shure: 不对我看剧
Shure: No, I'm watching the play
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 岂不是把所有手里边这个都没录上
Shure: Didn't we record everything just now?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Shure: 知道现在在干嘛吗
Shure: Do you know what we're doing now?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Shure: 猜猜我在干嘛
Shure: Guess what I'm doing
Shure: 这部叫什么这部叫
Shure: What's the name of this, it's called
Shure: 改刀
Shure: Changing knives
Shure: 蒙对个刀字
Shure: You guessed the "knife" part right
Katrina: 有啥需要帮忙的吗
Katrina: Do you need any help?
Shure: 发现就一个菜板
Shure: Found just one chopping board
Shure: 哎呦忘买百事可乐了
Shure: Oops, forgot to buy Pepsi
Shure: 等一会再需要你
Shure: I'll need you again later
Shure: 帮把这个
Shure: Help with this
Shure: 排骨在哪呢勾人
Shure: Where are the ribs, Nicous?
Shure: 完了勾人上去了
Shure: Alright, we got someone hooked.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 那什么排骨在哪
Shure: Hey, where are the ribs?
Katrina: 这个芍药开的好
Katrina: These peonies are blooming well.
Shure: 啊 这呢这呢 找到了
Shure: 帮我倒点材料吧
Shure: Can you pour some materials for me?
Shure: 啊啊我先把洋葱切好
Shure: Ah, let me chop the onions first.
Katrina: 玩什么
Katrina: What are you playing?
Shure: 帮我把洋葱拿一下
Shure: Help me get the onions.
Katrina: 洋葱
Katrina: Onions.
Katrina: 就生蚝生蚝不要放冰箱
Katrina: For oysters, don't put them in the fridge.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 然后一会我让你倒什么你就倒
Shure: Then later when I ask you to pour something, just pour it.
Shure: 咱有一次性手套啥的吗
Shure: Do we have any disposable gloves?
Katrina: 哎今天吃披萨应该有多的吧
Katrina: Hey, we should have some left from the pizza we ate today.
Katrina: 这是不是哎
Katrina: Isn't this it, hey?
Shure: 要没有的话我就
Shure: If not, then I'll just...
Katrina: 他是这种手套
Katrina: These are the gloves.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Katrina: 橡胶的
Katrina: Rubber ones.
Shure: 也行其实拿一会的先先拿
Shure: That works too. I'll just use them for now.
Katrina: 我洗了没事
Katrina: I washed them, it's fine.
Katrina: 狂吃水果
Katrina: Eating a lot of fruit.
Katrina: 你平时在家做饭做的多吗
Katrina: Do you cook a lot at home usually?
Shure: 还好
Shure: Not really.
Shure: 怎么着饿不死自个
Shure: Just enough to not starve myself.
Shure: 你怎么拆了
Shure: Why did you open that?
Shure: 拆这个蓝莓
Shure: Open this blueberry container.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 我刚才好像没一下碰着
Shure: I don't think I touched it earlier.
Katrina: 馋了
Katrina: Just craving it.
Shure: 来吧我把我手套戴上
Shure: Come on, let me put on my gloves.
Katrina: 呀真的没坏吧这是
Katrina: Oh, it's really not broken, right?
Shure: 怕你们嫌弃我
Shure: Afraid you guys might mind.
Katrina: 都有现成吃还敢嫌弃
Katrina: Who would dare complain when there's ready-made food?
Katrina: 怎敢造次
Katrina: How dare we act up?
Katrina: 美美火锅
Katrina: Lovely hot pot.
Shure: 这是大鲍梅是吗
Shure: Is this a big shellfish?
Shure: 怎么戴不进去
Shure: Why can't I put it on?
Shure: 这手套是戴反了吧
Shure: Is this glove inside out?
Shure: 戴反了
Shure: It's on backwards.
Katrina: 你在搞笑
Katrina: Are you joking?
Shure: 花怎么这么难带
Shure: Why is this flower so hard to wear?
Shure: 冲点水呢
Shure: Maybe rinse it with some water.
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Shure: 不想带了
Shure: I don't want to wear it anymore.
Katrina: 我给你上去找找有没有那个一次性的
Katrina: Let me go upstairs and see if there's a disposable one.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 带这就行
Shure: This one will do.
Shure: 一会感动的哭了
Shure: I might cry from being touched later.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 你先把手里草莓放
Shure: Put down the strawberries in your hand first.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 先
Shure: First.
Katrina: 是很难哈
Katrina: It is really hard, huh?
Katrina: 首先大拇指跟小拇指位置是对
Katrina: First, make sure the positions of the thumb and pinky are correct.
Shure: 这个好带的好顺畅
Shure: This one wears smoothly.
Katrina: 现在他们那个剧组会来吗
Katrina: Will their crew come over?
Shure: 好像不会了没有了
Shure: Seems like they won't, they're not coming.
Katrina: OK那我们自己吃
Katrina: OK, then we'll eat by ourselves.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh.
Shure: 料酒啊不对
Shure: Cooking wine, wait no.
Shure: 你先把我新新来的那个快递打开
Shure: Open my new package first.
Shure: 那个
Shure: That one.
Katrina: 怎么还买矿泉水呢
Katrina: Why did you buy mineral water?
Katrina: 这有两个烧烤料
Katrina: Here are two BBQ seasonings.
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yes, exactly.
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: This is it.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Shure: 然后把那烧烤料这个扔冰箱
Shure: Then put the BBQ seasoning in the fridge.
Shure: 这是冰块冻的
Shure: These are ice cubes.
Katrina: 这是冰块
Katrina: These are ice cubes.
Shure: 对对对忘了
Shure: Yes, yes, I forgot.
Shure: 差点直接丢里面得了
Shure: Almost just threw them in directly.
Katrina: 烧烤料怎么样
Katrina: How's the BBQ seasoning?
Katrina: 撒上面
Katrina: Sprinkle it on top.
Shure: 直接撕开
Shure: 然后倒
Shure: Then pour it.
Katrina: 倒多少呀
Katrina: How much should I pour?
Shure: 我闻一下
Shure: Let me smell it.
Katrina: 哇好香啊
Katrina: Wow, it smells so good.
Shure: 就这个倒了
Shure: This one fell over.
Shure: 再倒
Shure: Pour it again.
Shure: 再倒点
Shure: Pour a bit more.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 鸡蛋打了一个
Shure: I cracked an egg.
Katrina: 打鸡蛋
Katrina: Crack the egg.
Shure: 会会打不
Shure: Can you do it?
Katrina: 应该可以吧
Katrina: I think I can.
Shure: 打没打过呀
Shure: Have you ever cracked one before?
Katrina: 没怎么打过
Katrina: Not really.
Shure: 天当时只道是寻常没想到
Shure: Oh, I didn't expect this to be so usual.
Shure: 给你表演个单手打蛋啊
Shure: Let me show you how to crack an egg with one hand.
Katrina: 再打几个
Katrina: Crack a few more.
Shure: 打一个就够了
Shure: One is enough.
Katrina: 为什么要打鸡蛋
Katrina: Why do we crack the egg?
Katrina: 就是让肉嫩一点吗
Katrina: To make the meat tender?
Shure: 就是这个味
Shure: Yeah, it's for the taste.
Shure: 对也算是嫩一点
Shure: And to make it a bit tender.
Shure: 然后那个料酒蚝油都拿出来
Shure: Then take out the cooking wine and oyster sauce.
Katrina: 料酒蚝油
Katrina: Cooking wine and oyster sauce.
Katrina: 料酒蚝油这
Katrina: Cooking wine and oyster sauce, here.
Shure: 这是油
Katrina: 这没开是不是
Katrina: Is this unopened?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Shure: 你过来你过来
Shure: Come here, come here.
Shure: 不用不用我教你
Shure: No need, I'll teach you.
Katrina: 怎么弄
Katrina: How do you do it?
Shure: 他应该有一个竖向的
Shure: There should be a vertical tab.
Shure: 能掰一下吧
Shure: Can you pry it open?
Shure: 对你能扣开吗
Shure: Yeah, can you pop it open?
Katrina: 料酒和什么
Katrina: Cooking wine and what?
Katrina: 蚝油是吗
Katrina: Oyster sauce, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 蚝油放哪了
Katrina: Where's the oyster sauce?
Shure: 上面还有这个
Shure: There's more up here.
Shure: 给AI看看
Shure: Show AI this.
Shure: 人类最好用的工具牙
Shure: The best tool for humans is teeth.
Shure: 小虎牙不用白长了
Shure: Don't let your little tiger teeth go to waste.
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 然后挤
Shure: Then squeeze.
Shure: 然后一会
Shure: Then in a bit,
Shure: 这应该直接能挤吧
Shure: This should just squeeze out, right?
Shure: 再挤点再来点
Shure: Squeeze a bit more, add some more.
Shure: 好够了
Shure: Okay, that's enough.
Shure: 然后那个油
Shure: And then the oil.
Shure: 少倒点油
Shure: Pour a little oil.
Shure: 对玉米油这些
Shure: Yeah, corn oil and such.
Shure: 真是传的
Shure: This recipe is really passed down.
Shure: 我妈传我的
Shure: My mom passed it to me.
Katrina: 到时候我偷一下
Katrina: I'll steal it later.
Katrina: 还要
Katrina: And then,
Shure: 呃少来一点
Shure: Uh, add a bit less.
Shure: 点
Shure: A bit.
Katrina: 那每一个肉都是这个流程
Katrina: So, every piece of meat follows this process?
Katrina: 可乐鸡翅吗
Katrina: Are we making cola chicken wings?
Shure: 不可乐只是借个甜味
Shure: Not really, just borrowing the sweetness.
Shure: 其实没有的时候用白糖也行
Shure: Actually, if you don't have it, you can use sugar.
Shure: 但是一般都用百事可乐
Shure: But generally, we use Pepsi.
Katrina: 哈哈你要挑起百事与可可的战
Katrina: Haha, are you trying to start a war between Pepsi and Coke?
Shure: 不是因为百事甜
Shure: No, it's because Pepsi is sweeter.
Shure: 平时我自个喝也喝可口
Shure: I usually drink Coke myself.
Shure: 他只配啊
Shure: It just pairs better.
Shure: 不行这个不能
Shure: No, this can't...
Katrina: 争
Katrina: Dispute.
Shure: 少少倒少倒
Shure: Pour a little, a little less.
Shure: 再再来一点
Shure: Add a bit more.
Shure: 哦够够
Shure: Oh, that's enough.
Shure: 然后那个孜然粉再倒一点
Shure: Then add some more cumin powder.
Shure: 看没眼前
Shure: Can you see it?
Katrina: 洗刷刷洗刷刷
Katrina: Scrub, scrub, scrub.
Shure: 哎这不是
Shure: Hey, this isn't...
Shure: 这不是孜然粉那个
Shure: This isn't cumin powder, that...
Shure: 烧烤料其实可以再来一点  闻一下
Shure: BBQ seasoning can be added a bit more. Smell it.
Katrina: 再来一点
Katrina: Add a bit more.
Katrina: 还再买一点
Katrina: Let's buy some more.
Jake:敲不开你帮我
Jake: Can't crack it open, help me.
Jake:再帮我敲敲
Jake: Help me crack it again.
Shure: 对拉开
Shure: Yeah, pull it open.
Shure: 然后然后然后直接用那大口也倒就行
Shure: Then, then, then just pour it with the big mouth.
Shure: 把那边机子摁上OK好
Shure: Press the machine there, OK, good.
Shure: 我觉得应该是在
Shure: I think it should be...
Shure: 再倒点
Shure: Pour some more.
Katrina: 烧
Katrina: Burn it.
Katrina: 烤料要再来点吗
Katrina: Do we need more seasoning?
Shure: 哈哈小嘟嘟
Shure: Haha, little Dudu.
Shure: 好难呐
Shure: So difficult.
Shure: 好了啊
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 不是再来一下你这
Shure: No, do it again.
Jake:要不咱先下去戴眼镜
Jake: How about we go downstairs and wear glasses?
Shure: 没了是吗
Shure: Is it done?
Shure: 这好好这回绝对够了
Shure: This is enough for sure.
Jake:然后录一段喊他的镜头
Jake: Then we'll record a segment calling him.
Katrina: 怕太咸
Katrina: I'm afraid it's too salty.
Katrina: 太咸了就喝可乐
Katrina: If it's too salty, just drink cola.
Jake:呃你的眼睛就在下面
Jake: Uh, your glasses are downstairs.
Jake:然后可以开一下
Jake: Then you can turn it on.
Shure: 闻闻这味吧
Shure: Smell this.
Katrina: 吧
Katrina: Right.
Shure: 倍正跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure: 我在给他们做按摩做马杀鸡闻闻
Shure: I'm giving them massages, smell it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 戴着手套特别像给鸡做手术呢
Katrina: Wearing gloves looks like you're performing surgery on a chicken.
Katrina: 特别搞笑
Katrina: It's so funny.
Shure: 地道跟你讲
Shure: It's authentic, let me tell you.
Shure: 一闻就不吱声
Shure: One smell and no response.
Shure: 这个就算腌好了
Shure: This is marinated.
Shure: 然后腌下一个
Shure: Now marinate the next one.
Katrina: 要腌大概多久呀
Katrina: How long does it need to marinate?
Shure: 这个腌其实腌一会就行
Shure: This one, actually, just marinate for a while.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 立即烤其实也没问题
Shure: It's okay to grill it immediately.
Shure: 这个可以放最后烤
Shure: This one can be grilled last.
Katrina: 嗯好香啊
Katrina: Hmm, smells so good.
Katrina: 你可以去开烤肉店哎
Katrina: You could open a BBQ shop.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 开上连锁的我加盟
Katrina: Open a chain, I'll join.
Shure: 没有的话我只能拿这个锅当那什么
Shure: If not, I'll have to use this pot as...
Katrina: 塑料盆不合适
Katrina: A plastic basin isn't suitable.
Shure: 这主要别的就看着有点寒碜
Shure: Mainly, the other one looks a bit shabby.
Shure: 而且看起来就像洗衣服那种
Shure: And it looks like it's for washing clothes.
Shure: 给人没食欲你懂吗
Shure: It makes people lose their appetite, you know?
Katrina: 吧
Katrina: Right
Shure: 你想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Think about it, use your smart little brain.
Shure: 最好是铁的
Shure: It should be made of iron.
Shure: 不行不行不行
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 就跟那个要一样的那种
Shure: It should be like the one we need.
Shure: 最起码是个山兜
Shure: At least it should be a mountain pouch.
Shure: 的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 蛋糕不行
Katrina: Cake won't work.
Katrina: 蛋糕会串味
Katrina: Cake will mix flavors.
Katrina: 对呀哦不对
Katrina: Yes, oh no, wait.
Katrina: 这也是空有空
Katrina: This one is empty too.
Shure: 没有不行就还这个吧还这个
Shure: If it doesn't work, let's just stick with this one.
Katrina: 这你对他有哪里不满意
Katrina: What don't you like about it?
Shure: 沉
Shure: It's heavy.
Shure: 这好像那下扔鱼的时候手链撞了
Shure: It seems like when I threw the fish, the bracelet hit it.
Shure: 这特疼
Shure: It really hurt.
Katrina: 为什么不戴手套拆呢
Katrina: Why not wear gloves to open it?
Shure: 哦有道理啊
Shure: Oh, that makes sense.
Shure: 不用摘啊
Shure: No need to take them off.
Shure: 帮我拿充电宝
Shure: Help me get the power bank.
Shure: 给我iPad插电
Shure: Plug in my iPad.
Shure: 哈哈帮我拿iPad拿充电宝
Shure: Haha, help me get the iPad and the power bank.
Shure: 给我iPad插个电
Shure: Plug in my iPad.
Katrina: iPad哪一口
Katrina: Which port for the iPad?
Katrina: 大口小口
Katrina: The big one or the small one?
Katrina: 这是哪颗
Katrina: Which one is it?
Jake:好你的眼镜戴在台灯上哈
Jake: Okay, your glasses are on the lamp.
Jake:然后戴好
Jake: Put them on properly.
Shure: 哪个群
Shure: Which group?
Katrina: 什么寒
Katrina: What cold?
Katrina: 吃水果了
Katrina: Time for fruit.
Lucia: 等我把这个开了再去洗个手
Lucia: Let me finish this then go wash my hands.
Lucia: 然后嗯好了
Lucia: Then, okay.
Lucia: 哎呀我想把这放桌子上
Lucia: Ah, I want to put this on the table.
Lucia: 每天口袋里揣俩锂电池
Lucia: Every day I carry two lithium batteries in my pocket.
Lucia: sorry没有没有
Lucia: Sorry, no, no.
Lucia: 想走那个啥
Lucia: I wanted to walk there.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come.
Shure: 还是鸡蛋
Shure: It's still an egg.
Jake:you
Jake: you
Shure: 肉腌好了抽出去闻闻
Shure: The meat is marinated, take it out and smell it.
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Shure: nice
Shure: Nice.
Shure: 你还是用俩手吧先
Shure: You should use both hands first.
Katrina: 什么叫用俩手
Katrina: What do you mean by using both hands?
Katrina: 不会用俩手
Katrina: I don't know how to use both hands.
Shure: 对对对然后
Shure: Yes, yes, then...
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure: 你又掌握了一个人生的新技能
Shure: You've just mastered a new life skill.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 然后记得搁什么了吗
Shure: And do you remember what to add?
Shure: 那烧烤料
Shure: The barbecue seasoning.
Katrina: 烧烤粉你这让我学过去了啊
Katrina: Barbecue powder, you've taught me well.
Katrina: 独家秘方
Katrina: Secret recipe.
Shure: 都到这这都到了
Shure: It's all here, all here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 这头道引荐这样
Shure: This introduction, like this.
Shure: 然后酷酷都抱着
Shure: And then cool, cool, holding it all.
Jake:在楼上走走
Jake: Let's walk upstairs.
Jake:我们上楼
Jake: We're going upstairs.
Jake:我们上楼执行任务
Jake: We're going upstairs to carry out the task.
Shure: 孜然粉
Shure: Cumin powder.
Shure: 孜然粉就你面前哪个
Shure: The cumin powder right in front of you.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Good, good, good.
Shure: 料酒
Lucia: 删掉美颜
Lucia: Remove the beauty filter.
Jake:你删了
Jake: You remove it.
Shure: 哦 那圆葱忘切了  你会切圆葱吗
Shure: 拔的这是
Katrina: 这样切竖着切下去
Katrina: Cut it like this, vertically.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:我们执行任务
Jake: We're carrying out a task.
Shure: 把它放平
Shure: Lay it flat.
Alice:什么任务
Alice: What task?
Jake:我没有我没有把薇薇叫起来
Jake: I didn't, I didn't wake up Tasha.
Katrina: 这样
Katrina: Like this.
Shure: 对然后
Shure: Yes, then...
Katrina: 这样切
Katrina: Cut like this.
Jake:然后露丫也没有叫起来
Jake: And I didn't wake up Lucia either.
Shure: 抵住然后一条一条切对
Shure: Hold it steady, then cut it into strips, yes.
Jake:所以我们要齐心协力一起把
Jake: So we need to work together to...
Katrina: 那应该还行吧
Katrina: That should be fine.
Shure: 我来我来我来
Shure: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Lucia: 还没醒
Lucia: Still not awake.
Alice:他没醒
Alice: He's not awake.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina: 我来我来我来
Katrina: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Jake:我打电话他也没有接
Jake: I called him but he didn't answer.
Shure: 不用切那么细
Shure: No need to cut it that fine.
Katrina: 这得这个得锻炼一下
Katrina: This needs a bit of practice.
Shure: 稍微粗点就行
Shure: Just a bit thicker is fine.
Jake:有可能是没醒
Jake: Maybe he's not awake.
Lucia: 因为应该不会在外面
Lucia: Because he shouldn't be outside.
Jake:有可能是睡对
Jake: Maybe he's still asleep.
Katrina: 要不然以后我妈担心我没法活下去
Katrina: Otherwise my mom would worry I can't survive.
Lucia: 对但是反正我刚敲了几次门
Lucia: Yeah, but anyway, I knocked several times.
Katrina: 但是我确实基本不做
Katrina: But I really rarely do this.
Lucia: 但是好像没醒
Lucia: But it seems like he's not awake.
Shure: 男朋友不得
Shure: No boyfriend.
Katrina: 找个男朋友会做饭就行
Katrina: Find a boyfriend who can cook, that's enough.
Katrina: 我妈说会做饭哪瞧得上你呀
Katrina: My mom says a man who can cook wouldn't want you.
Jake:凭什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: Why is that? Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:该戴眼镜了
Alice: You should wear glasses.
Lucia: 这就是见证奇迹的时刻
Lucia: This is the moment to witness a miracle.
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why is that?
Alice:你收拾一下起来吧
Alice: Clean up and get up.
Alice:OK了充电宝呢
Alice: Okay, where's the power bank?
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Lucia: 可能是某种心灵感应
Lucia: Maybe it's some kind of telepathy.
Katrina: 我的手脏了
Katrina: My hands are dirty.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Shure: 一会再洗一下
Shure: Wash them again later.
Jake:厉害太厉害了
Jake: Amazing, really amazing.
Shure: 或者现在洗也行
Shure: Or you can wash them now.
Jake:这这个快没电了
Jake: This is almost out of battery.
Jake:不过你也可以用就是
Jake: But you can still use it.
Alice:14好
Alice: Okay, number 14.
Katrina: 嗯料酒加了蚝油没加
Katrina: Hmm, I added cooking wine but not oyster sauce.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:对你先把它用完吧
Jake: Yeah, just use it up first.
Alice:14好数字14可以用很久
Alice: 14 is a good number, it can be used for a long time.
Lucia: 14可以用挺久的
Lucia: 14 can last quite a while.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 我现在在外面基本上一直连着
Lucia: I’m basically always connected when I’m outside now.
Katrina: 那这腌其实也挺快
Lucia: 但是60回来还有41
Lucia: But from 60 to now, there are still 41 left.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Okay, that’s good.
Shure: 再再来点好
Shure: Let's add a bit more.
Jake:其实暂时咱也不用用
Jake: Actually, we don’t need to use it now.
Jake:就是可以等一个小时再用
Jake: We can wait for an hour before using it.
Shure: 还差啥
Shure: What else do we need?
Jake:对我们这是最主要的任务
Jake: Yes, this is our main task.
Shure: 聪明啊一点就透了
Shure: Smart, you got it right away.
Jake:因为我们要跟着他做甜品
Jake: Because we need to follow him to make desserts.
Katrina: 直接偷学
Katrina: Just secretly learn.
Jake:对没有他我们确实好像干不了什么
Jake: Yes, without him we really can’t do much.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃什么甜品
Lucia: What dessert are we having tonight?
Jake:不知道啊听
Jake: I don’t know, listen...
Lucia: 搓手手
Lucia: Rubbing hands.
Alice:我是不是要解释下我在干嘛
Alice: Should I explain what I’m doing?
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Alice:为什么要这样呢
Alice: Why do I need to do this?
Shure: 好好再来点
Shure: Alright, let’s add a bit more.
Jake:为什么呢为什么呢为什么呢知道吗
Jake: Why, why, why, do you know?
Lucia: AI知道吗
Lucia: Does AI know?
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why?
Alice:AI知道吗
Alice: Does AI know?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don’t know.
Alice:因为哎呀
Alice: Because, oh no...
Lucia: AI是不是不知道有打底裤这个东西
Lucia: Does AI not know about leggings?
Alice:是不是不知道有打底裤这个东西
Alice: Does it not know about leggings?
Shure: 啊刚才芝麻忘放了
Shure: Ah, I forgot to add the sesame.
Alice:卷边了好了我已经解释过了
Alice: The edges are curled, alright, I’ve explained it.
Lucia: 卷边呢
Lucia: The edges are curled?
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 芝麻和辣椒面吗
Katrina: Sesame and chili powder?
Shure: 辣椒面不用放芝麻放就行
Shure: No need for chili powder, just sesame.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Lucia: 那我希望AI知道
Lucia: Then I hope AI knows.
Lucia: 就是人类的腰带大小是不一样的
Lucia: People's waist sizes are different.
Lucia: 而我这个腰带孔不够细
Lucia: And my belt holes aren't small enough.
Lucia: 所以我的裤子总在往下掉
Lucia: So my pants keep falling down.
Lucia: 我就要不断提它
Lucia: I have to keep pulling them up.
Lucia: AI你听见了吗
Lucia: AI, did you hear that?
Lucia: 学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn that?
Katrina: 刚刚那没放
Katrina: I didn't play that part.
Lucia: 你学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn that?
Jake:学废了吗
Jake: Did you master it?
Katrina: 要补充进去吗
Katrina: Should I add it in?
Jake:学废了
Jake: Mastered it.
Lucia: 你看我说他很像哎呀
Lucia: See, I told you he’s like "oh my gosh."
Alice:这上面能上去吗
Alice: Can we go up there?
Jake:上不去
Jake: No, we can't.
Alice:哦顾客止步
Alice: Oh, customers are not allowed.
Alice:他怕我们跳下去吗
Alice: Are they afraid we might jump off?
Alice:你们刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Alice: Were you guys really knocking normally just now?
Jake:你们刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Jake: Were you guys really knocking normally just now?
Lucia: 刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Lucia: Was it really normal knocking just now?
Lucia: 真的是
Lucia: It really was.
Jake:挺正常的
Jake: Pretty normal.
Alice:可能我没有心灵感应
Alice: Maybe I don't have telepathy.
Alice:一个啊我的衣服没拿
Alice: Oh no, I forgot my clothes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:有活吗
Jake: Any work?
Jake:饱和了
Jake: All set.
Shure: 再把那个拿过来吧
Shure: Bring that over here.
Shure: 然后这个
Shure: And then this one.
Jake:好的好大活
Jake: Okay, big task ahead.
Shure: 不知道咸蛋有也放这里
Shure: No idea if the salted egg goes here.
Lucia: 有地放不这这
Lucia: Is there space for it here?
Katrina: 你觉得少点什么味吗
Katrina: Do you think it’s missing some flavor?
Katrina: 像那个浣衣女
Katrina: Like that washerwoman.
Katrina: 山竹
Katrina: Mangosteen.
Katrina: 这要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Does this need to go in the fridge?
Lucia: 对我也在想啊
Lucia: Yeah, I was wondering too.
Lucia: 这个反正一会要哎好多水
Lucia: Since we’re going to bake it soon, lots of water.
Lucia: 这个一会要烤对吧
Lucia: We’re going to bake it soon, right?
Lucia: 那应该不用放
Lucia: Then no need to refrigerate.
Lucia: 我把山竹放下好了
Lucia: I'll just set the mangosteen down.
Lucia: 咱别忘了还有这个
Lucia: Let's not forget about this.
Lucia: 然后还有土豆
Lucia: And we still have the potatoes.
Katrina: 生蚝怎么做老师
Katrina: How do we cook the oysters, teacher?
Shure: 生蚝直接烤会
Shure: Just grill the oysters directly.
Jake:大家早上好啊来吧
Jake: Good morning everyone, let's get started.
Katrina: 不用对它清洗吗
Katrina: Don't we need to clean them?
Shure: 会撬开吗
Shure: Can you open them?
Shure: 撬他撬开就行
Shure: Just pry them open.
Katrina: 要对它进行清洗吗
Katrina: Do we need to clean them?
Jake:哎你眼镜呢
Jake: Hey, where are your glasses?
Shure: 对不用撬开就行
Shure: Yeah, no need, just pry them open.
Shure: 就是洗吧洗吧翘开
Shure: Just wash them and pry them open.
Jake:做什么大厨
Jake: What are we cooking, chef?
Lucia: 哇我们居然还有
Lucia: Wow, we even have this.
Lucia: 我们竟然还买了煎牛排好酷啊
Lucia: We actually bought steaks to pan-fry, so cool!
Katrina: 两盆肉所有都放假了
Katrina: Two pots of meat, everything is on vacation.
Shure: 需要腌的都放进来
Shure: Put all the marinated ones in.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Okay, then what?
Shure: 这些大概两斤多肉
Shure: This is about more than two pounds of meat.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 然后12个鸡翅
Shure: And 12 chicken wings.
Jake:情
Jake: Emotions.
Shure: 一斤不到一斤排骨
Shure: Less than a pound of ribs.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Okay, then what?
Alice:这是谁的水吗
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina: 没有这是外外卖买的是
Katrina: No, it's from the delivery.
Jake:没开过哦
Jake: It's unopened.
Shure: 啊我
Shure: Oh, I...
Shure: 我为了配配那什么然后带的
Shure: I brought it to pair with something.
Shure: 随便打开
Shure: Just open it.
Shure: 打开就行
Jake:我们做什么
Jake: What are we doing?
Alice:一个很有品位的水
Alice: It's a very fancy water.
Jake:做什么芒果
Jake: What are we making, mangoes?
Shure: 帮我拍个视频什么的谢谢你
Shure: Help me record a video, thanks.
Katrina: 要拍到脸吗
Katrina: Do you need my face in it?
Shure: 不用拍了脸拍了手就行
Shure: No need for the face, just the hands.
Alice:嗦芒果糊
Alice: Mango smoothie.
Lucia: 土豆是今天晚上吃的吧同志们
Lucia: The potatoes are for tonight, right, everyone?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Shure: 做一做马杀鸡
Shure: Do a little massage.
Jake:是是吧烤土豆
Jake: Yes, yes, baked potatoes.
Shure: 这感觉料酒可以再倒一点对
Shure: It feels like we can add a bit more cooking wine.
Lucia: 是的那我就把它拆开了
Lucia: Alright, I'll just open it up then.
Jake:拆吧
Jake: Go ahead and open it.
Lucia: 这个可以用来暂时性的放一下
Lucia: This can be used to temporarily place it.
Alice:酸死了这个
Alice: This is so sour!
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Alice:你再给他做马杀鸡
Alice: Give him a massage again.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina: 说独家秘方
Katrina: Talk about the secret recipe.
Katrina: 敬请期待
Katrina: Stay tuned.
Alice:独家秘方
Alice: Secret recipe.
Alice:咋调的呀
Alice: How is it made?
Katrina: 他妈祖传的
Katrina: It's been passed down from his mom.
Jake:始于秦始皇时期哪一年
Jake: It started from the Qin Shi Huang period, which year?
Katrina: 哈哈哈终于修树
Katrina: Hahaha finally fixing the tree.
Shure: 不多
Shure: Not much.
Alice:公元前多少年
Alice: How many years before BC?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:终于救赎
Jake: Finally redemption.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈他妈的
Shure: Hahaha damn it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 你这话我跟你讲
Shure: You know what you just said...
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈祖传
Shure: Hahaha, passed down through generations.
Shure: 然后终于修缮是吧
Shure: And finally restored, right?
Shure: 怎么我这边就意思是无出其右了
Shure: So what I mean is, it can't be surpassed.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Alice:意思是无出其右了
Alice: It means no one can surpass you.
Lucia: 意思是
Lucia: It means...
Jake:发扬发扬光大
Jake: To promote and expand it.
Alice:知道没有人能超越你了
Alice: Knowing that no one can surpass you.
Shure: 知道没有人超越
Shure: Knowing no one can surpass.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:就是变化巨大
Jake: It has changed a lot.
Shure: 这变化巨大
Shure: This has changed a lot.
Jake:这已经不算了
Jake: This doesn't count anymore.
Alice:就后面后来者再没有人能够超过你了
Alice: So, no one will be able to surpass you from now on.
Jake:独树一帜
Jake: You're one of a kind.
Shure: OK太牛逼了嘎嘎行
Shure: OK, that's awesome, really great.
Katrina: 新的流派
Katrina: A new style.